- What have we got here?
We have the whole set up
for the Mogen David ad, 1957,
including the slides,
the progressive proof
that showed the whole process.
And it ended up to be in
the "Life" magazine, and
other magazines, right there.
OK.
This is neat that
you have all this.
This is the 1950s, and
Mogen David saw a market
that needed to be exploited.
MATT: Right.
It's just the United States
really wasn't into wine.
After Prohibition,
everyone was used to really
bad beer and really bad booze.
[laughter]
[burping sound effect]
MATT: I am selling the Mogen
David proof ads class slides,
including the original ad,
but it was in "Life" magazine.
I got them at an estate
sale because they're cool.
I think I can make some
good money off of them.
I'm hoping to get $500 for them.
The least amount of
money I'll take is $200.
This is really, really cool.
This was a really tedious
process back in the day.
Today, take a digital camera
and it does all the work.
But back then, you had
to develop the film,
and then you had
to decide how many
colors you wanted to do it in.
So this one was
four-color lithography.
They take a color photo.
Now, they take that
negative for that and they
put it in a machine, and
they put a bunch of filters
across the front of it.
And they filter out
everything but this red.
MATT: Right.
- OK?
And they make this glass slide.
They get it down so now they
have these four negatives.
Each one of them
are for each color.
And then it goes to
the printing press
four times for each color.
And in the end, you get this.
MATT: Wow.
It was a really drawn-out
process, but that's the way
they did it back then.
MATT: OK.
I mean, you got some
interesting stuff here.
What do you want to do with it?
MATT: I'd like to sell it.
OK.
How much you want for it?
Well, I'm asking $500.
OK.
It's really, really cool.
And these glass plates, I
mean, they're interesting.
And they tell a really cool
story to, maybe, someone
in the advertising business.
But no one's going to buy them.
There's nothing
collectible here.
OK.
Sorry to hear that.
Thanks for coming
by, though, man.
I appreciate it.
- Thanks.
[music playing]
I was kind of disappointed
he wasn't buying them.
I'm bummed, but I
learned a lot today.